いいえっ
[拍手]
ブーブー今回は正崎さん
卒業言いまして100万円企画第4弾
つか乱れ夢は100万円
100枚馬崎君はここ6年間社長のお手伝いを
非常に頑張っていただいたということで卒業記念プレゼント振ることで
100万円を
grep したいと思いまーすといないと思うんですけどもうそうだよ
こちら見ルーレットでこそ位ただ100万円をあさきさんに渡すのではなく100万円
の高い道を
パのブルーですね勝手に感を決めさせていただきたいと思いますこちらのルーレット0
が2つ
市から36の数値がありますそれを回してもらって
魂がこの頃ってなったスーツ
な当たりも吸ってたんですけども数字によってたイメージが決まります
まずゼロかそれぞれを出した瞬間ありがとうございます現金100万円でございます
ぽぽすげー
車が欲しいと発射ていましたね産まないで100万円前後でございます
[音楽]
戦前にあるということでこそから100万円を受けると思います
一があるとカーでて生まれなんと号皮肉100万円
ああすごい
みんな rrh ポッチー nous ウードゥー
に育てられましたよねそうです前に使う100万円
コレいいねしあわせになる人が多いそう
親子発てないたいという意味を込めであるということ
北管理これが高校もしれない
募集現金以外から一つ好きなのを選んでください
要するにこの中からいやの一つ言えバーンがあるというけど最後は募集です
終了3536が出てしまうと
募集になってしまいます
あればなぜこういう引き当てる to speak な作
なぜ募集するとにこれなっているか30
8分の3な理由
てるでしょでないず会社よっ本のことがないと出ないし約200万円てればもう何に
見合ってもらっても困るも青いでも良いけどもう行っとられたわからん
入ってるみたいになるんじゃねーなー心の準備はよろしいですよ
1緊張する前から休みに敵さん狙いは
狙いはね今感動を考えると親に使う客前からだ
的にするか決めるギリスって現金100万円ですか
いやまず一発長打かねこれ9-0よろしいでしょうか
うぇい
the moon
dai
who are too
ええええええ
皆さんねー
ます
はぁ
[拍手]
恋によっこれを追った
nara nai
[拍手]
tan tan
持っていてにゃん
ます
ん
うひー全然はい36番ということで
募集ねーむーそうでしょこれ
[音楽]
me
uh
car
あっはぁ
まずでも数段と
[音楽]
ok ok じゃないよっ kei
ん
ございますデイ止めますじゃないよ
くっ